ara introduced the new track to
creatures it's a great honor to you
present the winner of the Nobel Prize
literature and great honors
insidious of a broom and the future
wright and patrick modiano
your majesty your royal highness
excellence sheikh laureates
ladies and gentlemen the ceremony that
just unfolded me deeply
moved ch and shows generosity and
of the grace with which you have me
received among you that I will not forget it
I'll never forget the
kindness and delicacy of
members of the Swedish Academy that I have
could meet
I have the impression that they made me
to enter with a magic wand
in this pantheon where many appear
Heroes of my youth
what they gave me envied to be
writer and whose reading helped me to
live in the hours of loneliness of
adolescence
I would like this reward
far from my say towers gives me more
lucidity and humility your job
as a writer and that she inspires me
more just vision of beings and life
as an old dreamer I can not
to stop me from thinking about these swedish people
romantic destinies have been linked to
France
axel of fersen august strindberg raoul
nordling i'm so affected
to be honored and stockholm
this city that I love and in sweden
this country to which I am attached by
the mind and by the multi tax choir